♪ ♪
>> Tucker: FOR DECADES THEY
TOLD US IT WAS ESSENTIALLY
NECESSARY TO BECOME ENERGY
INDEPENDENT BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT TO RELY ON THE MIDDLE EAST
BECAUSE THEY HATE US AND WE HAVE
TO FIGHT ALL THESE WARS TO
PRESERVE OUR ACCESS TO ENERGY.
WE DID BECOME ENERGY
INDEPENDENT, WE PRODUCE ENOUGH
ENERGY FOR THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
IN FACT, THE MOST ROBUST SECTOR
OF OUR ENTIRE ECONOMY SO
JOE BIDEN NATURALLY DECIDED TO
CRUSH IT FROM DAY ONE IN OFFICE.
HE TOLD US HE HAD TO DO THAT
BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
AOC AND ALL THAT.
IT WAS NOT LONG AGO THAT
JOE BIDEN CALLED FOR A FOSSIL
FUEL EXECUTIVES TO BE JAILED.
>> WE SET THOSE SORT OF GUIDE
RAILS DOWN NOW.
BETWEEN THE YEARS 2021 AND 2030,
IT'S A REVERSIBLE, THE PATH
WE'VE SET OURSELVES ON AND ONE
IS DOING AWAY WITH ANY SUBSIDIES
FOR FOSSIL FUELS, NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, HOLDING THEM LIABLE
FOR WHAT THEY HAVE DONE
PARTICULARLY IN THOSE CASES
WHERE YOU ARE UNDERSERVED
NEIGHBORHOODS AND, YOU KNOW THE
DEAL, OKAY.
AND BY THE WAY, WHEN THEY DON'T
COME UP WITH THEM IN JAIL.
I'M NOT JOKING ABOUT THIS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> I'M NOT JOKING.
>> Tucker: OKAY, SO ENERGY AND
THE ENERGY GRID IS BOTH
INCREDIBLY COMPLEX AND ESSENTIAL
SO LET'S PUT A GUY WITH A
FUNCTIONAL IQ OF 75 IN CHARGE OF
POINTING IT OUT.
THAT IS WHAT WE'VE DONE AND GAS
PRICES ARE OUT OF CONTROL AND
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE THAT.
NOBODY LIKES OUT-OF-CONTROL GAS
PRICES BECAUSE YOU NEED TO GAS.
WE DON'T HAVE SOLAR CARS YET.
NOW JOE BIDEN HAS CHANGED HIS
VIEW.
CLIMATE CHANGE ISN'T THAT BIG A
DEAL, CARBON EMISSIONS AREN'T A
HUGE PROBLEM AND THEY ARE COMING
FROM CHINA OR THE MIDDLE EAST
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN HE'S GOING
TO END HIS CAMPAIGN AGAINST OUR
OWN ENERGY INDUSTRY.
THEY ARE STILL IN TROUBLE,
FACING PRISON TIME.
INSTEAD JOE BIDEN CALLED A
MIDDLE EASTERN THEOCRACY'S
MEMBERS TO PUMP MORE OIL SO GAS
PRICES HERE WILL GO DOWN.
WHAT DO WE MAKE OF THIS?
WITH "THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER,"" SHE
JOINS US NOW.
I DON'T THINK I HAVE SEEN A MORE
PERVERSE AND REVEALING POLICY
THAN THIS ONE.
EXPLAIN WHAT IS GOING ON HERE,
IF YOU WOULD.
>> ACTUALLY, IT IS SORT OF
BEFUDDLING WHAT IS GOING ON.
AS YOU POINTED OUT, THE ENERGY
INDUSTRY IN THE UNITED STATES
HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MOST ROBUST
SECTORS IN OUR ECONOMY, LEADING
RIGHT BEFORE THE PANDEMIC,
PRODUCE MORE OIL THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD AND WE WERE
SELF-SUFFICIENT IN THAT AREA AND
NOT ONLY WAS THAT A JOB CREATOR,
AND NOT ONLY JUST DIRECTLY
WITHIN THE ENERGY INDUSTRY BUT
ALSO THE DOWNSTREAM INDUSTRIES
THAT SUPPORT IT, AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEN THRIVE ON
IT AND THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
BENEFIT FOR IT.
IT ALSO WAS VERY IMPORTANT IN
NATIONAL SECURITY, WHICH IS WHY
I THOUGHT IT WAS CURIOUS TODAY,
THIS NATIONAL SECURITY HAD WAS
TELLING, ESSENTIALLY BEGGING THE
OPEC COUNTRIES TO PRODUCE MORE
OIL, AND OIL HAS BEEN -- I MEAN,
THE ENERGY INDUSTRY, JOE BIDEN
HAS PUT HIS FOOT ON THE NEXT
SINCE DAY ONE AND THERE IS NO
EXAGGERATION IN THAT STATEMENT,
FROM HIS EXECUTIVE ORDERS ON THE
KEYSTONE PIPELINE TO HALTING
AND/OR PAUSING PRODUCTION ON
FEDERAL LANDS WITH FRACKING IN
NEW MEXICO AND ALSO OIL
PRODUCTION IN LOUISIANA, HE HAS
IMPACTED LIVES, AMERICAN LIVES
PROFOUNDLY RIGHT THERE.
>> Tucker: WE'VE GOT TO GET
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE, SO WE DO,
NOW WE HAVE TO BE MORE DEPENDED
ON THE COUNTRIES THAT HATE US IN